pump the brakes there gang got a quick
poor update that stayed trashy tour is
taking over the country you know it they
don't know what to do adding shows
adding cities come out and see us live
stand-up comedy play the lay YG with the
crowd great way to introduce people to
the show come out and see the boys yeah
Gang This March we're starting in
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia then we're going to Oklahoma
City Dallas Texas Houston Texas Austin
Texas second show added there then we're
going to New Haven Connecticut as of now
it's sold out we're working on the
second show and we got Burlington
Vermont we got Tampa Florida first show
sold out second show is about halfway
sold out get those tickets Dania beats
Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Kentucky just added Cleveland
and Columbus get those tickets let's
party gang see out there on the road
yeah welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the girl to
be classy yeah they're just a big old
piece of trash trash trash I'm your
hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement the construction
upstairs continues and it's driving me
crazy it's a lot there's a huge hole in
the wall I know outside I know I'm up
there eating my cornflakes I got my nuts
in my throat and not to mention a couple
of those contractors were peeking at me
while I was brushing my teeth this
morning and I don't know what she's
doing up there she's playing two ends
against the middle yeah she's robbing
Peter to pay Paul I think she's sleeping
with old
I saw her I saw her move in a unit that
[__] copper out the back I think
she's taking that right to the yard I
don't know if uh condoms are usually in
a toolbox but they got a shitload of
them up there my co-host is coming at
you from across the table this is a
family up episode just the squad this
week he is the CEO of are you garbage
she is an international businessman any
business increase please direct them to
Mr Kevin James Ryan
what's up gang business inquiries please
get business inquiries lawsuits
non-construction permit Clauses whoa hey
what are you talking about this guy's
nuts don't listen to him he's been
drinking
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure your rate of you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
fantastic love it and obviously the
greatest gosh darn website of all time
I'm talking www
patreon.com are you garbage check it out
baby it's a good time to get episodes of
bonus episodes of hard feelings episodes
of uh bonus episodes ayg hard feelings
Vlogs the whole nine yards all the goal
videos are up there check it out gang
it's a good time over there in that
patreon we're having fun oh yeah and
speaking of fun having a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones works the twos and he's
got that big old wiener wiener give it
up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dude the kids here
look at them I got a question for you
fellas I'm listening so the clocks just
change spring brutal fall back [__] me
up oh it ain't great I sent a text to
the group at 4 15 a.m hey let's do 11. I
thought I got some bad liquor I don't
know what the hell was going on in a
wormhole came out an hour later Another
Universe so my my IPA Wormhole
what the hell what a question to you
fellas am I hungover yeah is is your
oven clock wrong half of the year or do
you change it oh I catch it around June
maybe you know
I think mine's wrong
I don't I've never changed it maybe to
maybe the Mist maybe the bird does it
doesn't catch back up though it does
it's here it's good for half the year
it's good for half the year so right now
if it's off it'll be right again next
April yeah but my next march mine was
off but now it's smooth sailing all
right look at you on time
slept like a baby
uh it don't make no sense
that dumb [__] okay what does that
exactly do uh I don't know it was for
Farmers the almanac the moon that's all
bullshitting I think somebody was just
telling me that was little the biggest
fluff I ever heard yeah that was wheat
barley you don't know that was the point
now what I don't know it was for Farmers
they get an extra hour of sunlight but
then I think everybody just what no they
don't
the sun doesn't stay up longer dude this
is this the the Sun
rise and sunset changes every single day
oh my God it's the stupidest reason of
all time what it's a for candles
what Benjamin Franklin couple good ideas
on that guy this one's [__] stinks
Benjamin Franklin invented the concept
in 1784 believing that Rising earlier
would Econo economize candle usage and
save people money
no there's got to be another reason to
it I just heard it was for the the
somebody voted Congress or the house or
somebody did something where they're
wiping it clear yeah because it's stupid
yeah it is stupid yeah it is stupid it
was adopted during World War One as a
part of a global attempt to conserve
energy
Ben Franklin was around a World War One
damn that guy got around Jesus
my favorite President
as syphilis makes you look longer
apparently he got weird huh I think you
got him back then right what the [__]
else you got to do how could one do do
that that's crazy
you find out the kite was tied to his
balls
it's this weird way to jerking off go
out in a storm and let it tug on his
root a bunch okay we're gonna leave that
part out of the story what that's the
best
but this is my get my jokes out I've
always been pissed at him not pissed I
don't have a beach
this guy owes me a c-note damn have a
cup of decaf for you
God but I think I could invent a bunch
of stuff when nothing existed you know
what I mean you think it's hard to
invent stuff now everything exists what
you gotta do you gotta be pretty [__]
tight that guy's like I need something
to write with I'll make it there you go
yeah now you gotta like [__] split
the atom to make the newspaper he was
just stumbling across [__] yeah he's
like hey I need to do it I can't see and
I looked through this glass jar I see
better let me throw some glass jars on
my face did he invent glasses bifocals
what really yeah Pam where do you go to
school
that's crazy
no way he invented bike yeah he did what
was he Rich when he died and he also
invented the sybian I heard
I knew Ben Franklin butt plugs
he did invent the urinary catheter yeah
dick tubes bro Jesus well dude imagine
if it was what 1776 and your dick hurt
you'd start shoving [__] up there to
figure it out man
you see what I'm saying I don't get it
man dude nothing existed it's easy to
make stuff they had no water back then
no Plumbing no showers how did he have a
clear head to [__] think through all
that [__] hey we're all done they're all
doped up drinking smoking he also
invented swim fins what are those like
fins for when you're swimming like scuba
guys that's easy too you see a shark I
need those come on come on give me
something to help I'll tell you how you
invented
well I mean that's like that's like oh
you got to put Wings on a plane cause a
bird has them he invented the odometer
and then your ancestors have ended
rolling it back
shout out to Cousin Eddie he didn't
invent the odometer what yeah he did how
was that possible there was no car yeah
there was no cars you know what else he
has catalytic converter I swear to God I
heard he came up with the Wi-Fi routers
no
one of the original Partners in MapQuest
the ones you had to print out
nothing more trashy than that [__] again
yeah if somebody's Toyota Corolla
there's a bunch of [__] MapQuest
stayed with coffee on the floor my Dad
tried to figure that [__] out holy [__]
like a Polynesian trying to [__] use
the Stars to get to an island that was a
hard one
yeah
I just squeeze that in yeah he's been
working on that they they the government
tasked him with trying to get the the
mail in order because the post service
was all slap Dash so was he the only guy
so he invented what's going on he
invented stamps.com
promo code garbage was everybody else a
[__] idiot
is [__] man I love him don't get me
wrong Philly all the way what the [__]
the whole country of Foley's the one
give me yeah
what the [__]
man I'm telling you I'd be venting a lot
of [__] back in the day a lot if I was
smarter I would do it now any idiot can
make stuff we're getting up and it's
still dark out what do we do change the
time there you go you want to save
candles make it lighter earlier boom go
to bed come on
man shout out to Benny Frank though
shout out to him Benny with the blue
face that's right
um used to go over to France a lot do a
little
get weird how do you get over there
boats yeah
that's a rough vacay yeah no he invented
the jet ski what the [__] you think
these Waters here he's got the bar in
his mouth
man have you ever gone water skiing
chubs I've tried yeah you got pulled
behind the boat I'm sure I got drunk
through the Kevin Costner in Water World
yeah I got drugged through the bay in
Ocean City a couple of times yeah
um I was up there at Lake wall pull pack
is that how you did it yeah we had uh
we'd go up the mountains put a boat in
the water there cruise around I just
laid on the knee board because I didn't
have the upper body strength to pull up
my plumber torso out of the water
yeah no I tried when I was uh probably
like 13 14.
that didn't work and then started doing
drugs
shortly after my water skiing crew was
immediately over started running this
slalom if you know what I mean I had no
future
um and then I tried uh
I think it was
maybe kneeboarding or something okay or
maybe it was water excuse in the
Schuylkill oh [__] keep your mouth
closed buddy
radioactive ways
my buddy's girlfriend's parents had a
house on the Schuylkill which I thought
was strange I didn't know anybody [__]
around on air the Delaware right maybe
that's a little bit cleaner yeah but and
they uh they had a little [__] boat
and she was really good and I couldn't
get up then they broke out the the the
thing the tube or inflatable yeah and my
buddy was driving and he was [__]
around oh and gave me you know gave me
the little Shimmy Shake dude parts of
that school kill it's [__] rocks all
over the place and it's about two inches
of water I almost [__] slammed into a
goddamn tree
I'm telling dude he [__] launched me
yeah that's like a big dirt bike thing
is like dump him and you [__] we cut
the wheel left real quick yeah how you
do that in the ocean all right whatever
oh she can go tube it in the ocean or
whatever dude where you're not in a
[__] single Lane of rocks and trees
catfish or whatever the [__] is down
there okay if you ever do battle tubes
two tubes one boat two tubes one boat no
I never did I never did you a jackass
what are you talking about
Toby McMullen welcome to tubing
um nah I never you do it in the parking
lot of a Walmart
shopping carts uh I never uh I don't
think I've ever been to actual tubing I
find that to be shocking I know I think
because I always knew I was just gonna
get really hurt because I get hurt so
easily and I was just like and I'd be
stupid I would do stupid [__] I would
get hurt but even that one I'm like
that's gonna [__] me like that's like
really gonna hurt me you've gone tubing
down to Delaware though right where you
just float oh yeah we used to do that on
our own in the Neshaminy Creek oh man we
go up to Vinnie with the skinny shout
out to him shout out uh we'd go to like
Kmart buy a couple of tubes one for the
cooler a buzz uh and then this is how
trashy it was dude when you get to parts
or the wall there's a creek it's not a
river the water's so low you'd have to
get out and like whoa [__] walk I got
a pair of [__] vans on and I'm walls
watching no stepping in that slimy water
nope serpents lurk uh seen a couple of
[__] water moccasins I don't like
that [__] I don't like that yeah I
didn't like it either I'd be thrown
[Laughter]
sorry those iguanas that swim oh that's
why I was saying I was in Puerto Rico I
thought one was something got something
that's always going to jump in it yeah I
don't like it um
we would we would park at the park right
Tyler Park
still some State Park the Neshaminy
would it have to be after like a big
rain yeah we yeah yeah we checked the
water she had if you're playing in
rainwater
and I have
the creek at Townline used to [__]
flood when it rained oh and it was going
like the retention Pond we'd get a tube
and like that would turn into a lake
we'd go in there
I'm trolling
pull up a sophomore
but we would have we'd get to the park
and like people be like eating you know
we would park a car at the park drive up
to venues
get in they'll get in the water at
Vinnie's float all the way down two
three hours or whatever and the card be
waiting for hard be waiting for it it's
pretty smart uh but then we tell people
you have like picnics and stuff we'd be
like covered in mud [__] coming
through the woods with tubes at like 24
years like way too old to be doing that
it was a like walking in on a birthday
party it was [__]
walking through it yeah
it was a bad time it was a rough look
for sure ah it's funny good old days all
right Gang This is a family episode as
you know when you sign up for the old
patreon there you can have your question
read on the air here with the boys
and we'll do that now I don't like when
you do that stop doing it and we'll be
right back I don't like to have a
[__] TV presenter presenter I always
get jammed up I I feel like you paint
yourself into a corner a little bit and
you turn into Tom Brokaw your whole life
um all right let's see this one's from
Michael ever call a doctor's appointment
a reservation
I got a table for two down here at Dr
persiketty's
that's tough I do get it though yeah it
feels going to the doctor feels fancy
that's funny yeah
um
this one's from trash compactor have you
ever been to a place that has a
Cowabunga Burger
I don't know what that it sounds trashy
give that a goog T-Bone T-Bone a
Cowabunga bird I feel it's got to be
pineapple or something I'm all about
that Cowabunga is Hawaiian or something
or like Surfer yeah Cowabunga dude yeah
it's Ninja Turtles yeah but I think
maybe it's Turtle meat I don't know
Turtle Birds Turtle burgers
I got a lot I gotta line a lot of food
trucks It's gotta be beachy I feel
that's my take okay Cowabunga this one's
pretty good it's it's a burger but the
lettuce is like the the Teenage Ninja
Turtles face and then it's bacon like an
eye mask that's pretty good oh that is
amazing wait but it's so it's just uh
I think if I was making a Cowabunga
Burger
it would be two patties
Special Sauce lettuce cheese grilled
onions
grilled pineapple and you gotta fight
ninjas while you eat it swiss cheese and
I'm a huge rat
and
[Music]
um spicy mayo that would be the
Cowabunga bird okay at Foley's sounds
like a pretty that's just like a
standard Burger I feel like with
pineapple though oh yeah I put some
pineapple yeah grilled onions pineapple
mayonnaise swiss cheese and spicy mayo
okay
huh double up on the Mayo mayo and spicy
mayo no just spicy mayo okay Burger
um all right let's see uh
let's stay in the line of food this is
from Cody Klein yeah heavily invested
shareholder never have one red is it
garbage to put we talked about this
garbage to put extra toppings on a
frozen pizza
I don't like it I don't do it
hard to get an even cook on that what
are you talking about no it's it is
garbage but it's awesome I don't
I think I might be turning on that if
you got your own [__] in the in the
fridge you get a frozen pizza say it's a
pepperoni all right I would then feel
the need to not add anything to it I
would go maybe hot sauce after she's
cooked you could put some onions and
peppers and uh
olives on there a little sausage Cooks
cook sausage make a supreme
people do it I tell you what my that's
too much though it's like just go buy a
[__] Supreme Pizza my Instagram feed
is really fun so if you have all that
[__] readily available sausage peppers
onions olives in your cooked sausage in
your [__] fridge just make something
else you know what I mean make a dish I
could see if he got a plain one he
throws some pep you got some [__]
crumbled up bacon or whatever something
like that maybe some additional cheese
Instagram has been really feeding me
weird things uh the algorithm it's all
it's all mismatched cooking stuff like
uh chocolate chip cookies and a waffle
maker it's got you dead the rice oh they
got me cold making a homemade no
invented the algorithm Benjamin Franklin
there you go that's not true of course
it's not true oh
but it's pretty good
I don't know guys all over the [__]
place he could have uh-huh I heard he
also invented Spice TV okay let's talk
about that manscape baby oh what are
they not getting into over there they
got everything they carry from head to
toe that man they got your beard covered
they got your nuts covered they got your
ear covered they got your nose covered
and I don't know about you fellas out
there I need all that stuff now I use it
on my butthole too I'm at nose hair age
oh yeah oh yeah ear hair too oh it's all
over the place do yourself a favor get
that package get that lawnmower 4.0 get
the weed whacker get the nut spray
straight straighten yourself out because
here's the thing what Spring's coming oh
you got to be fresh you gotta rake the
leaves the broads are gonna be
oh you know what he'll be tearing at you
you don't want to be pulling that thing
or guys if that's your if that's yeah
let's go uh the package also comes with
the big man said the crop preserver ball
deodorant fiber ball toner baby keep
them high and tight who don't who don't
like a tight sack keep them nuts pickles
let's go always use the right tools for
the right job head to their website now
and check out all of their tools to get
an upgrade on your hygiene routine all
jokes aside you gotta keep it tight what
are we doing here yeah you sweat less
you smell better at the whole nine yards
uh save 20 off and free shipping with
our code garbage at manscape.com that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com manscaped your
balls well thank you gang today's
episode is sponsored by our good friends
at geez got em on right now baby oh gee
baby love sheath to death got to meet
the owner out there at skank Fest yeah
shout out to Robert great guy Good Time
games gotta have a hog on them because
these are these are big wiener
Underpants they are yeah if you if you
got a big got a thick cut
yeah but it's still nice they slip them
in there a little separation yeah keeps
everything dry you don't need eat it but
I'm saying if you got a big unit these
are even better for it oh I don't I
don't need to wear pants are you kidding
me you won't be able to see nothing of
course walk around like Winnie the Pooh
but if you want to keep the keep
everything fresh down there it keeps
your balls sick to your legs it keeps
your dick on your ball every it just
separate everybody's
compartmentalized a little bit that's
all that matters it's got two pouches
one for your one for your Berry like a
hot pack of gummy bears and stick it
together uh she's underwear comes in a
ton of cool patterns helps you look good
and feel comfortable I call them my sexy
underwear I've been using them for years
I buy them on my own I buy them I've
been buying I was buying them before
they were even sponsoring the gosh darn
show I was buying them uh so go to
sheathunderwear.com and use code garbage
to get 20 off your first order uh been
with us since jump one of our first
advertisers of all time so support the
people who support the Pod baby plus
sheets underwear is 100 money back
guarantee that's sheathunderwear.com
promo code garbage get sheath underwear
support the show support your balls back
to that gosh darn show back to the show
all right this one's from John Fitz is
it garbage to have a car with no reverse
that's a tough look do they make them no
it's because the car is broken and
doesn't go in reverse they're not no
one's making a car with no reverse
that's a tough sell on the lot
you get half off on that hey buddy you
save 80 bucks a month but this one don't
go backwards and you only got three
tires
uh kid I grew up with had that uh in a
conversion van it becomes that I think I
might have had something like that
did my my Honda Accord hatchback that I
had started to not do something I can't
remember what it was uh-huh maybe no
e-brake who needs an e-brake how often
are you using unless you live on the
side of a hill I don't think I had park
or something like that I always had to
use the e-brake
is that possible
I don't think that would pass inspection
you gotta [__] I didn't say I was
getting an inspected okay fair enough
um we knew a guy my body and a kid grew
up with had a conversion van that he had
to only pull into spots where he could
pull out of
you know what I mean yeah like pull into
his neighborhood a certain way so he
could like [__] just loop around or
you got a park on a hill
stomping ghost Whip and work drop it in
neutral
all right let's get the [__] out of here
uh you're riding around going around the
house
mom's like what the [__] is he doing uh
that's uh that brings up a tragedy thing
that we used to we do a lot
we would you've been to my you know the
Denise's house oh yeah right otherwise
yes I've been when I was formally
invited by you of course platonically
while you were there as friends don't
say plutonically that implies something
else
because the only other version is
romantically
uh this is followed by a real quiet at
first
[Laughter]
you look over you smoking hey we got to
talking
oh it's raining
we would
pull if so like at the driveway you
could park
real two cars but real snug three at the
front of the driveway
in the back of the driveway where the
garages yeah we're like the basketball
net was but they call that the front
that's the back of the driveway up the
driveway
pull all the way in
the front of the driveway is down by the
mailbox if you're parking down there
you're a [__] oh you're jamming
everybody off of your parking down there
um but we will oh you're getting the
driveway done oh yeah block it off
uh-huh
um
don't pull in the driveway they're doing
at it they go in the driveway tomorrow
Patty's crazy about that [__] what where
everybody put don't pull in behind me I
gotta leave
so you can just [__] go around the
grass my stepdad's move rest in peace
was to block everybody in whenever
people were over so he had to go out and
move his car to catch Stingers I gotta
go move the car
I'll keep moving that card 19 [__]
times leave it in the street that's a
good time though moving the cars when
somebody I gotta put a car back out and
then you do the wave they're all out in
the driveway [__] goofing around
maybe you and your uncle walk out he
[__] lets one go I've been holding
that in for a while ah dying laughing
let you drive no eyebrow humor I see
over there at the police it wasn't
George Carlin wearing your uncle farted
um
but we will whatever all right so we'll
get jammed up because there's only
it's wider at the top yeah yeah like
most driveways yes and so if you're
jammed up we'll pull around the house
we'll drive you go all the way around
yeah yeah it's the only way to do it so
we drive in the backyard up the side
we're grass drivers through the front
yard back on and then [__] zip out
yeah we have that nice little Hill in a
really big space between uh you know the
grass to the next property and wow we're
all over that yeah all over that
especially as a kid my dad did my dad
had a
66 Mustang sitting up next to the garage
and that was it wasn't on cinderbox but
it was on the grass for about two years
yeah beehive City oh yeah yeah yeah but
you know what it made me think of
I'm not proud of this at all and
somebody could have got seriously
injured sure I'm listening but
did you ever back in the day people
would leave their doors unlocked their
windows down in the cars
our neighborhood was on a hill
were you ever rolling around with your
boys
and you put somebody's car you put the
E-brake down in somebody's car put it in
neutral and let it roll down the hill
what yeah we did that a couple of times
no that's such a dick move dude never
[__] up someone's car they lose their
job get get back on the hooch start
shooting up lose their kids I didn't do
it personally Joy back pedal but I'm not
backpedaling but that's what they called
it
hey the back pedal the old man Jenkins
Corolla there was maybe like one or two
years maybe like 12 13. or I was a real
piece of [__] everybody has that though
for sure no were we really got into
Mischief Night like we were in it heavy
but that's a regional thing though for
the listener if Mischief Night is the
night before wait what yeah I think
we've talked about this like over a year
or two ago
do not everybody know what Mischief
Night is so I think it's like a
Northeast thing and it's also big in
Michigan oh yeah for uh every night's
Mischief Night Detroit I don't know if
you've been on Instagram
those boys love Michigan
hey waiting for no candy corn to give
them the green light yeah they ain't
soaping up your windows either all right
um it's the night before uh I should say
Thanksgiving the Night Before Halloween
you go out and do Mischief like that
that's crazy
you know toilet paper or I throw in the
tree soap the wind like kid stuff you
know what I mean yeah doing [__] B
and ease or anything
[__] Smash and grab at the jewelry
store safe cracking okay stethoscope two
more minutes I made the call Safe Credit
call went out the call went out dressed
as a zombie
um yeah like one or two years we really
got into it like planned it out for like
a week and went around [__] egg
people's houses we had a BB gun and we
had like these bay windows and uh one of
my buddies [__] clipped off a couple
of [__] shots into somebody's window
like fired at the house not really
paying attention it hit the window
shattered the window
[__] bolted [__] cop cars were
doing [__] parallels [__] for like
an hour
we were on one street and we were
walking I think this was the next night
we were trick-or-treating caught
red-handed with a bunch of crayon
blueprints
now who's that fat piece of [__] right
there
it's clearly me and chocolate bar in my
hand
um
somebody dropped this guy's e-brake and
the car rolled down the hill and it
wasn't like you know it wasn't like it
would have killed somebody it was like
there was like a couple
maybe like four car lengths there was
there was a car behind it but the dude
caught us
and [__] showed up at my [__]
buddy's house yeah he was not a guy
not a guy you want to [__] with sure no
shirt [__] ripped jean shorts [__]
long hair February
and he's like who the [__] yeah you
[__] up his ride [__] pissed [__]
you don't [__] with a man's ride we uh
but things are different back in the day
now you I mean well you wouldn't be able
to do it but they would call the cops on
you
he just [__] screamed at us and
threatened to [__] beat the [__] out
yeah he should have beat the [__] out of
you yeah jamming them up like that
probably had a hot date with a nice
piece of trim these tight little Bobby
was what I remember uh he looked like
the kid from
stranger things the redhead the
redheaded girl's brother you don't want
to kick our ass hot guy like you
said we come upstairs and we'll figure
this out the red-headed girl from
stranger things you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah but but but
way buffer
didn't beat us up
we had a couple of close calls like that
where we should have got the [__] kicked
out oh of course we my it was snowing
one night we're at my buddy's house
we're probably 20. Jesus Christ I was
13. yeah no we're like probably 20 maybe
21 ish College Years
snow and we're all boozed up at some
kids I don't even know the kid we got
this family tied up upstairs
they're letting us hang around you're
judging me
I don't even know I got Clockwork Orange
it was one of those things of like
nothing a friend of a friend was going
we and it was like a weird Crow it was
like hey it's uh it's gonna blizzard
tonight let's ball go somewhere whose
parents are gone or whatever when you're
at a friend of a friend of a friend's
house he went to us that's when problems
start happening you know because you
don't respect the house I don't respect
the guy I don't respect his parents his
mom can go [__] herself yeah uh that's a
top shelf situation right there and I
think it was a bad I just remember being
like the kid went to our school for a
little bit you know what I mean it was
like one of those like he had uh you
know I forget
or they're drinking snow and then couple
kids go out kid shows up in the middle
of the year don't trust or leaves in the
middle of the year no bueno they uh or
you better have meningitis dude you
better get mono what's [__] Happening
Here do you ever get mono nah I think my
think Danny had I think my brother had
it in like seventh eighth grade or
something like that yeah he was scoring
not me
can't get her from a sleeve of Ritz I
did have a tennis elbow at a young age
what about you you ever get mono what's
up mono yeah oh I'm not cool
it was cool but let's get out it was
cool together people were dying and
people were falling out no [__] you up
for like weeks or like months do you
ever Google that dude mono can really
[__] you up yeah no no yeah nucleosis I
remember dropping that on people
thinking I was a [__] doctor he's got
my Oh you mean mononuclear I I bro I'm
sorry yeah no I just know so many Manas
you have to what's your course of
treatment a lot of doctors are
recommending Gatorade these days ginger
ale with crushed ice uh two to four
weeks some people may feel fatigued for
several more weeks and will be called a
[__] for months
also known in the neighborhood as the
trollop
hahaha
clear sign hickeys on the neck I'm
throwing rocks tonight
although
treatment is confession twice a week uh
so we uh you get up there clean yourself
up but oh there was a girl in my high
school the only girl I knew who got mono
also received for her birthday someone
got her a pill crusher and she was like
this is the greatest gift I've ever been
given it's like God where'd you go to
school sing sing a pill crusher
what the [__] Bill Crusher and a cup of
noodles
sitting pretty
hey man I got your new wallets in my ass
you got to wait until I [__] I had to
get it past the guards
um what were you saying wait so you're
at a house a couple of kids go out to
like oh let's just go outside it's
snowing we'll have beers out like we'll
drink in the snow that leads to like you
know a little bit just tossing snowballs
to then as the cars are coming by we're
gonna start [__] beaming those right
I love it we talk about that I'm [__]
go ahead
I [__] love doing this so I wasn't
really apart I think I was I was think I
was hanging out at the driveway having a
couple two tree Stingers with the boys
you know what I mean cop and other kids
are like down on the street you live
right by Main Street and he [__] you
know whatever guy gets
hits they hit us this dude's car that
snowball he gets pissed snowball it's
like dude come on you know a snowball so
I guess he thought he was gonna scare us
but he doesn't know he's playing with a
couple like not me but the kids are you
know a little [__] half cocked you
know a few cards sort of this is an
adult
an adult but we're also adult we're like
21. oh it's not like we're like 13.
that's like so he turns around
and gets out of the car like we all kind
of start running like ah [__] he's like
oh it's funny my buddy [__] doubles
back around the car Hops and the car and
takes off
oh man and like that's why you don't
[__] with these kids
take your lumps and keep it moving I
thought they threw a rock at you it's a
snowball you're in a goddamn blizzard
now you got your car stolen you got
chanted up in that ass is that there
your sweatpants falling down that's my
biggest fear he got Crocs I'm trying to
chase people yeah James Young that would
be me dude
yeah that's [__] no good
um
snowball's one thing we would we would
all sleep at my buddy's house this is
this is ninth grade eighth grade
we'd sleep at my buddy's house like five
or six of us either Friday or Saturday
of the weekend and the little click of
girls that we were friends with would
sleep at one of the girls houses and we
would sneak out at night
walk over there hang out all night come
back sneak in the morning if that wasn't
happening we'd sleep over and we would
go out and we would
the like they're called like monkey
brains you know those like weird things
that hang off the trees
they look like fruit but they're not
going to go to school the Congo
they look like avocados
crab apples Not crab apples I would eat
them you kidding me nah I don't know all
right yeah
um if you let those when they fall on
the ground and start getting on you know
start juicing up they were a good soft
thing to Peg cars and we'd [__] sit
out there like literally [__] in the
trees and [__] light cars up and then
[__] run yeah and then just kind of
like do that all over in the middle of
the night yeah yeah funny don't do that
though kids in different time now
that'll Jam you up they'll [__] put a
book at you
guy got real pissed came around and
[__] drove up on the on the uh
property yeah headlights coming through
a [__] yard sure
it wasn't sticking around for that prom
night me and some friends were doing a
little drinking driving hit some guy
threw him in a river
foreign
[Laughter]
I was like Wow Toby's gonna talk about
drinking and driving on the [__] show
that's crazy as you eat this
let's try to pass off movie plots so
there I am a genius solving problems no
one else can solve
d
I want Christmas I go out that later see
my ex-wife she's got this big office
party
I got no shoes on okay what movie is
that oh I've never seen it we've talked
about this this is old hat
I've seen parts
um that's crazy I know man I know uh
uh not a fan
I don't do it for me there's good stuff
you don't like like what celery
I do like celery dipped in chocolate
that's crazy because die hard's like a
movie for guys like you I super cool hot
dudes all right I'll check it out bald
guys yeah [__] oh come on man bald guys
are fighting with their wife I'm sorry
I had
you say we talked about it's crazy that
I forgot you forget everything dude man
get the brain of a goldfish what
are you in a car
if the cops called on me
uh all right let's see let's get this
show back on track God damn it we're all
over the road
um
this one's from Rice-A-Roni 10 home he
never had a question red is it garbage
that's all right I know you're a fan
your Die Hard can kick rocks I'm a rhony
man I don't even need the meat or
whatever the protein was boxing at
straighten your right full saucepan of
that going
just to the perfect amount of liquid
yeah we've mentioned it before but when
there was some left in the pot that was
always the best because it like cake
together
[Music]
not bad
um all right where were we racer Roni
never had a question right is it garbage
if you ran out of oil to heat your house
so you have to use diesel fuel for the
weekend
that's can't I don't know if that's how
that works you can't just put your own
gas in there can you damn who's Still
rocking oil a lot of people really well
yeah yeah yeah older houses no [__] yeah
yeah you see those trucks all the time I
see the trucks I see the trucks in the
city yeah doing the buildings wow yeah I
think a lot of people do that to think
about that yeah a lot of suburban a lot
of some
Toby you look perplexed I've never heard
of this you've never heard it well
heating oil no really canola Olive baby
but I'm an evv name myself a house
you've never seen the trucks pull up
like the they're like they look like
it's like a gas tank but they're smaller
they pull up they hook the hose up guys
covered in oil
now that I think of it I don't see them
in the city as much as I used to like
when I lived up here the first time all
the time I assume they're phasing them
out to what though if it runs on oil
what do you mean I'm not sure I don't
know about any of this city Steam Heat
but what's the oil for then
Toby
I mean we are a couple of wait a minute
hold on I thought the entire city was
Steam Heat but I do see the oil trucks
in the city the for the boiler for the
boiler that turns on to heats the water
hot water that heats the but doesn't the
Steam Heat the hot water what man we're
[__] done no steam doesn't heat the
hot water it doesn't steam comes from
hot water steam once was hot water
okay
maybe that's where the steam heat comes
from or that oil oh man I mean where's
Ben Franklin when you need them explain
some of the [__] to us
what's the word all right so you can use
uh oil in two two different types of
heating implementations you know a
boiler system or a furnace system and it
basically just replaces the natural gas
you would burn you burn the oil instead
of the gas yeah I knew that so that's
what he that's what's driving the Steam
Heat in New York City is Is Earl
right uh uh I don't know man otherwise
we're just the [__] super I don't
know or is the Steam Heat in New York
City come from boilers
yeah and the boiler gets not uh oil
right yeah and the oil came from
dinosaurs
Triceratops because it's chilly out
right now right Toby uh just say yes yes
hey there you go big man score one for
the big man that's gonna make it sound
nice and cozy not in the city but uh
like it's like a hot like an old
suburban house when when I'm you know
what my aunt and uncle's house I think
had oil because you could smell it when
when they Crank that [__] on it had
like that yeah well this guy's house
smells like diesel it's like living in a
tractor trailer for the weekend that's
crazy that's nuts I don't I mean but I
guess I don't think that one where are
you getting the D's [__] siphoning
them from the neighbor's house you're
getting you're going down to the gas
station I'm getting you buying a pinch I
guess I don't know have you ever put gas
in something that wasn't supposed to be
in no my buddy didn't have the red thing
my buddy oh like a container yeah yeah
water bottles
burning down houses
I was in Austin for three years fighting
frogs on fire no yeah we would uh
uh I love those red things or like
whatever if you needed it for [__] oh
the red things were great you always had
a good one and a bad wow love that smell
it's all right
uh I told you we put gasoline in a
[__] water bottle to like go like
fires in the woods or whatever
and the tip it was like we used like a
nozzle like a spray bottle it was like a
squirt bottle I didn't realize in the
end of that got like you see the videos
now where like it travel that fire
travels up to the bottle yeah dude sweet
you're stupid yeah and the end of the
bottle caught on fire so we like
panicked and we're spraying it was like
[__] shooting streams of [__] dude we
I full blown I want I in my head
immediately 4 000 homes burnt down and I
started running I was like and we threw
it in though because we were buying like
a by like a little Crick we threw it in
there and now the the gas is now just on
top of the water on fire and I'm
thinking the devil has come to [__]
guy do to panic I'm like we [__] up we
cursed You Pockets it'll be [__] up so
bad the water's on fire dude it was like
it was like 10 a.m in the morning too
[__] we were at Flip's house yeah it's
all right not too shabby
um
all right let's see he what do we get
uh this one's from Isaac is it garbage
to change your Wi-Fi network name to
send a message to your neighbors my dad
once changed our Wi-Fi name to stop
smoking on your front porch that's
pretty good that's pretty good I never
did that nah Toby I feel like you're a
guy who changes the the the thing not to
like as a passive aggressive move but
you just keep standard well that's a
good read I'm too lazy and I just keep
it and get pissed off when I can't
remember what life I'm supposed to be on
yeah I know uh
Big Boy Roy British investor here nice
gentlemen is it garbage the same thing
to have passive aggressive Wi-Fi name
and hopes your neighbor sees it my dad
said his to I hate this [__] at number
eight about 15 years ago after she
blocked his car in one time
wait there were two different questions
yeah whoa look at that the homies mind
melting weren't working together I like
that
um
yeah we do uh never the Wi-Fi I mean my
mom doesn't know what how to change the
Wi-Fi I just didn't know how to get in
uh I would never change it's just out of
pure laziness and now they make them
relatively easy
like it's like my wife my Spectrum or my
Verizon W whatever whatever and then the
thing the passwords now are like just
words instead of like
zxbh9478 Fiverr it'll just be like you
know
cold soup 442 or whatever
we never had real beef with any
neighbors like that
oh we did well we were doing like
passive aggressive stuff a little bit
with one
but she was kind of in the right
when we get back there and that pool and
all that [__] and [__] animals the
dogs barking the kids are screaming
they're fighting [__] grills going
[__] Motown music blasting you guys
are line dancing yeah is it yeah so she
just wanted to put in a couple of trees
to uh
oh yeah that's real passive aggressive
that's what you know defense the high
fence the trees I would do the same
thing too if I if I had a piece of
property give them some privacy I would
[__] throw up a big boy
you know what I mean so I can swim in my
undies
lay around
you ever swam when your parents pool
naked yeah
I've done a little skinny dipping in
there
during the day no what happened what are
you talking about
well Club fully after dark huh yeah
yeah you know with a lady parents are
upstairs asleep Patty
are you ready
I've gotten busted in there a couple of
times
sticking your little root in my in my
youth
they go up but like what did you think
it's the whole backyard
what do you mean there's nobody looking
there's nobody there I know but it's
someone's in if someone's in that pool
yeah you can hear them and anything we
weren't sneaking in they knew we were
going swimming yeah and they got caught
I thought they were up in bed
you know but what busts you is all the
lights are offered
right we don't turn the pool light on
yeah that's a dead giveaway what if you
don't have the pool light anymore
oh I almost zap somebody oh man the
above ground pool that pool's gonna be
on fire in a couple of weeks from the
depths of the hell
um yeah and my mom I think came down to
rip a heater or something like that was
like what what are you doing out there
the lights are off
quit fingering his [__]
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah
okay I never got caught pulling pulling
my root but I think I did get busted in
an intimate situation a couple of times
sure it jammed up one spot my dad he was
real pissed because there was no I
weren't even trying to hide it
you guys are on the kitchen counter
[Laughter]
on the watch
ing like Ricky Bobby
I mean ah man yeah it was after like a
real long night
he did God love me didn't say anything
but [__] uh later on in the afternoon
what the [__] [__] you doing in here
[__] mother was sleeping 10 feet away
where were you in the living room
California split level you can see right
now I was in my brother's room
so if you walk up those steps the to the
in the back yeah I mean you know where
the bathroom is upstairs
ain't that big all right though that's
what I'm saying I know you know where
the bathroom is yet but it's a telephone
booth with three doors on it I mean you
don't have to lay out the [__] roll
out the blueprints for me
oh that's uh that's why it was so [__]
up and sure in your brother's room is a
whole nother layer of rude too
um he was sleeping no I'm kidding who
you think was filming it he's got that I
didn't have a boom guy he was uh he was
in he was off he was in college
was an empty room
oh sure yeah no one from you heard any
furniture around no room for you her and
any furniture huh yeah that's a tight
squeeze in that room
uh all right let's see here this one is
from Cassidy haven't had one red yet uh
uh is it garbage to be born with a non
okay is it garbage should be born with a
non-life-threatening
congenital abnormality my dad was born
with six toes on one foot whoa I have
duplicated Udders what
boyfriend didn't have one of his adult
teeth
Etc it sounds like a rough Squad
Jesus Christ
X-Men Party of Three oh man holy [__]
the mutant to table nine I wanna I gotta
know what the the utter is utter I have
duplicated uh
urders ureters
urethra no unless you spell no it says
kidney to Bladder tubes type that in
yeah I don't like this I said internal
or extra she got poses coming out of her
she got extra tubes man she's I got a
liver on her shoulders I took a peek at
the profile yeah she's a pretty broad
yeah it's a damn shame about the udders
is it
um
okay
Gene duplication is fairly common this
seems to be not that common
uh it I'm getting a lot ah this is this
is a this is a goddamn
analytic paper uh what what it's called
when you get educated uh
uh yeah it's just like a tube
by your wiener or vagina is it out or is
it in it's in okay it's a couple of two
but how do you know I had a heart murmur
uh-huh
yeah it's not the same thing no I don't
think so okay academic it's like it's
all academic sites nothing is giving me
a real straight answer here sure I did
nothing in layman's terms nothing I can
understand looks like a different an
extra she got a couple set of tubes in
there okay that's all yeah one goes bad
you gotta get you know got a six toes
what's up with that do you keep that
did you get rid of it I think the
problem is they're never like
full-blown toes it's always like a
little nubbing or something sure I mean
it's never a fully formed sure guy if it
was fully formed I'd be like keep them
you know what I mean become one hell of
a magician yeah if you had six toes on
each foot I assume that would give you
an advantage right
with something rock climbing or
something I don't know combat tough to
get a pair of kicks though oh yeah
probably James yeah up walking in wide
boys
got a couple of [__] Hoagies on your
feet
yeah that's not uh
no that's not garbage but yeah it kind
of is I mean these chicks got others
dude no no it's your your readers
I don't know how to pronounce that
that's not it I'm no Benjamin Franklin
all right you can't type in your readers
I don't I did I did it's u-r-e-t-e-r-s
you are I just uh yeah I just you're
t-e-r-s here let's hear it said
oh I got it I got it I was fully
searching for duplicated utters ureter
okay gotcha uh it's a duplex kidney also
called duplicated ureters is a problem
with the urinary tract where there are
two ureters draining urine from a single
kidney it's more common in females than
males and it's in unpreventable birth
defect yeah don't sound too bad that's
all right there you go the toes wacky I
was boys with a kid who had webbed feet
I had never got that that's I would cut
it for sure oh it's making my blood run
cold you can't cut it why the [__] can't
you as an adult what can't just take
scissors to it I mean as a kid have a
have a surgery no I think I would just
cut it
I ain't pretty good in the water
probably he wasn't weird
huh it was only between his big toe and
the
the number to the the second in command
really that was it oh man wow we're at
Hockey Camp he jumped in the pool you're
like what the [__]
buddy call up Ben Franklin get some of
those [__] swimming fins cause you
stink I don't want to be looking get a
pair of Aqua Socks did they have it on
both sides of both feet I think it was
both big toes to the that's pretty sweet
to be honest with you I wouldn't mind
that
I mean that's gotta hurt your
self-esteem as like a eight-year-old kid
I don't know not if not if you're
[__] schooling them in the backstroke
he wasn't crazy I mean you know that's a
[__] you just don't want to be
different and then everybody's around
the pool go what the [__] Jesus Christ
the dads are looking at it weird God
damn fish boy that kid walks by looks at
his feet goes damn takes his shirt off I
worry about this anymore
me and my fat ass his kids got this
kid's half amphibious he's got fish feet
jump off
there's a cannonball this one's from
Jacob Berg ten dollar Bozo never had a
question red is it garbage to take the
tickets you get from Canon bottle
redemption and immediately use them to
buy scratch-off tickets what tickets do
you get for Canon bottle redemption the
money you get the money you get oh I
guess it gives you like like coupon like
uh vouchers okay like go cash in I guess
I'd like to supermarket you go put in
the bottles it'll give you a 10 voucher
you go to the customer service desk go
give me ten dollars of scratchers I'll
give you this voucher I mean that's just
a good business model
especially if that's what you're using
the money for of like hey I get I play
the scratchers but I only use my
Redemption money you're out there there
you go that's found money baby that
ain't [__] you know what I mean I
cash in the check and you know
like cash in your paycheck or [__]
taking a second mortgage out to play to
scratch sure hustling that's real
garyvee [__] yeah that's all right
flipping [__] hit a couple of yard sales
in your business those things are all
over the place now I feel like that's
become such a thing I mean it's just
because we live in New York I don't know
the bottle redemption stuff they're
[__] like every 10 feet it seems now
I mean that's a huge [__] business
people [__] go around and [__]
bang that stuff out throw it in a huge
truck yeah remember down at the New York
comedy club that one would pull up on
the weekends I mean they had a [__]
tractor trailer and an army of people
that's like uh scooping them up that's
like an ecosystem so it's like the guy
collects them sure he sells them to like
a middle man who's like I'll give you 20
bucks a bag or whatever sure that guy
then sells them to the truck guy or
whatever he they all it just like keeps
getting stepped on which now that I
think about it I'm sure they're [__]
somebody over because
we have recyclable recycle you have to
recycle in New York city so you put your
bottles and cans out whoever you're
hauling
person is
supposed to pick that up and they take
it to the recycling center but if they
get there there's no recycling
they're not getting their money when
they take it to the recycling center
right
they're like they're robbing the train
those those people on the street
they're sneaking in and taking the stuff
before the collection I don't think the
recyclable people get money for it
though
because it's all mixed anyway they're
just dropping it off yeah they dig
through you gotta you have to dig
because it's not separated
huh you know what I mean
they're digging for the cans because
it's all just mixed so the trash company
doesn't get money for the recyclables
that they drop off I don't think so I
thought they did
sounds like Mafia territory
I pay my bills at the end of the month I
kick up all right that's that but we
gotta wrap it up gang gang we love you
to death we're on the road
yes shows have been added shows have
been added we added a second show in
Vermont
we added a second show in Connecticut
Vermont Connecticut shows at it yes the
second Tampa show is going to sell out
the second Austin show is going to sell
out get those [__] tickets
all these we're moving tickets now Adam
come out party with the boys we'll see
you next week peace peace